Jenny 8ly how many times have you been
to Sundance so this is my tenth sundown
so you are well-versed on the different
prototypes of people there are walking
around Main Street here can you give me
a sort of smorgasbord rundown first of
all you have two filmmakers in towns you
know if you ever look at the credits of
the film you know there's so many people
that go into it so anyone who has a film
that's where they've contributed go and
like wants to be here then you
definitely have like the Hollywood
industry people and you can often tell
because they have like red badges those
badges to get into any film that you
want is about $2,000 for each half of
the festival so $4,000 for both halves
of the festival should those people are
looking for the next big thing looking
for the film's to acquire they'll bid
against each other you have a lot of
corporate sponsors mean Sundance the
film festival works in part because
there are big dollar corporations that
want to gain from this crowd they're
here doing business you know they're
cool they can bring client's or some of
their business partners to sundown so
you see some of those people walking
around and then you have a lot of film
fans or you know some man still has one
of most interesting and evocative
filmmaking in America here so there's
some normal people you know whether or
not they come from New York or Silicon
Valley or there's like a doctor in Texas
like people make some dancing a major
event
then you have a lot of crafts a lot a
lot of custom because this is a good
place to do work like you guys are here
where you see a lot of Hollywood in the
same place you see sort of like the next
big thing is you can like okay and about
trends and filmmaking at something else
it gets you good oh we shall open it
that's interesting about film festivals
like they seem really glamorous and
everyone there's something it's about
you know people in their snow gear
walking down Main Street moon bundles
yeah what film festivals really are on a
very fundamental basis as they are
business events right in there you the
the best festivals are valued because
that is where the most transactions
happen putting out an independent film
us is very different than putting out a
major studio release we're like two
students in studio release lighting a
big big budget big actors and you just
like you just you know pour money into
it
where's you have to be a lot more
strategic when you're putting out an
independent film thank you so much yeah
that was great
and we're out